all right a few things to sort of get
caught up on here as we still are seeing
2020's two results come in and so many
other different things want to get a
couple of ketchups uh uh going here
we have made it abundantly clear how
much is at stake
how much was at stake in 2022 and how it
relates to so much being at stake in
2024. just to I feel like I'm quoting
Rachel Maddow here to give you some of
the Contours and texture of really what
may happen in 2024 depending on the path
forward there's a stunning new article
in Rolling Stone from Ryan bort and
azawin subsang
about Donald Trump looking for ways to
imprison journalists jail reporters if
he is indeed able to retake the White
House Trump keeps musing about
journalists being raped in prison and
he's not joking they write
a knowledgeable Source tells Rolling
Stone that the former president has
wondered how he might be able to jail
reporters if he takes the White House
which of course is absolutely and
completely chilling you might remember
in fact I think we even have a clip here
Donald Trump telling these sorts of
stories about prison rape during Israel
from the Supreme Court first time it's
ever happened is just unbelievable but
you get the information very easily you
tell the reporter who is it And the
reporter will either tell you or not and
if the reporter doesn't want to tell you
it's bye-bye
the Reporter Goes to Jail and when the
reporter learns that he's going to be
married in two days to a certain
prisoner that's extremely strong tough
at me
he will say you know he or she you know
I think I'm going to give you the
information here's the leaker get me the
hell out of here yeah so that is a joke
about prison rape but it doesn't stop
there and this isn't merely idle uh the
article explains this year as Trump has
privately strategized about what a
second term would look like he's begun
occasionally soliciting ideas from
conservative allies for how the U.S
government and justice department could
go about turning his desires for
brutally imprisoning significant numbers
of reporters into reality several months
ago the former president briefly asked a
small gathering of allies and at least
one of his lawyers what would have to be
done to make that Vision a norm he said
other countries do it the implication
being why not here now you know as the
article points out Trump for a long time
has sort of idolized or at least looked
favorably upon the authoritarian states
that do exactly that type of thing North
Korea as the article says does not
tolerate free expression China and
Russia are well known for jailing
journalists or Bond the Trump endorsed
autocrat of Hungary has been targeting
reporters
etc etc Trump has also been praising she
in China for the so-called quick trials
with a nearly hundred percent conviction
of drug dealers in China followed by the
death penalty this is why he's so taken
with these sorts of folks and I here's
my desire you know we've done the
exercise in 2016 where many of us said
this is not an academic or theoretical
distinction
when you consider the Supreme Court
the attack on press Liberties all of
these things
Hillary Clinton for four years and
Donald Trump for four years could not
have been more different and all those
people who said let's shake it up let's
just see what happens if it's not Bernie
it's Trump then that's fine or I don't
see any real difference between Hillary
and Trump and I'll stay home or all the
people that were saying these things
we effed around and found out maybe
would be the way to say it and at this
point we need to believe the things
Trump says he would like to be able to
imprison journalists when they say or
write things he doesn't like
he's talking about it with allies and
he's talking about it with lawyers
let's not
explore or find out what will happen and
that's why as I said yesterday this
Trump descend to stuff I could not care
less about these individuals as people
my concern is how can they most damage
themselves and their party
such that none of them will win in 2024
and we will probably find that out
relatively soon
a couple things I did not get to this
week
um my pillow founder and CEO Mike
Lindell
was coping with the mounting losses on
Tuesday by simply saying it's all stolen
it is all fraud as it started to become
clearer and clearer on Tuesday night
there's no Red Wave there's like a
delayed red Ripple maybe and we're still
waiting for some of the results the
victory Channel brought him on I have no
idea what that is they said sir Mike
pillow please explain what's happening
and Mike pillow said listen they're
they're stealing everything that's
what's going on Mike tell us what's
going on by the way the idea of even
asking pillow what's going on is
hilarious they do here's what he says
well it's uh it's it's kind of what I
expected um they're stealing everything
um just did Herschel Walker's race alone
over 200 000 votes have been injected
into his opponent they've been injected
like bleach folks these are obvious
how many times you know it how many
times can they repeat the same stuff and
people will fall for it injection now of
votes to get to this runoff stage uh
they stole the governor's race in uh
with mastriano in Pennsylvania no
mastriano simply lost we've seen an
early injection of 90 000 posts by the
computer Shooters at Kerry Lake they're
trying to steal her so everything is
stolen everything is stolen this is
really the epitome of brain worms but
it's also the epitome of
if you have a hammer and all you have is
a hammer and you believe the hammer is
almost like a god
everything is a nail and this is all
they have left the truth
is not something they can accept the
truth is Trump hasn't been particularly
good for the party
one in 2016. 2018 wasn't so good 2020
wasn't good at all and 2022 was much
worse than expected it's not fraud it's
not injections or sauteing or grilling
or smoking or curing ballots it's not
salting and peppering of ballots it's
not it's not any of it
Trump is convincing these voters to
select terrible candidates for the
primaries
a lot of them are now losing it's
genuinely that simple and they are
throwing anything they can at the wall
and now what it is is the epitome of if
we won it was rigged
if we lost I'm sorry
if we won it was fair if we lost it was
rigged even on the same ballots and
that's one of the funny things you know
a few people emailed me
over the last couple of days about what
I tweeted years ago now about how is it
that they're saying on the same ballot
the presidential results were rigged but
the Senate and House results are
trustworthy when Trump lost but their
house or Senate candidates won and it's
starting to be the exact same level of
incoherence again why anybody would go
to Mike pillow for analysis I genuinely
don't know one more clip I want to look
at with you today
without making fun of anyone
one of the things we've been talking
about this week and last in the context
of the midterm elections
when doing interviews like our
correspondent Luke Beasley did at a
trump rally over the weekend we have
talked about we're not joking here this
is serious we've talked about how
difficult it can be to distinguish what
is a cult member who has been
brainwashed what is an ignorant person
and what is a mentally ill person when
someone says I think JFK Jr is alive and
is the president right now
is that something that you believe
because you're part of a cult
is that something you believe because
you just don't realize the truth about
JFK Jr and when he was killed and how or
is that something you say because you're
mentally ill or is it all three in some
combination the
epitome of this Venn diagram
is a tour called reawaken America
Eric Trump one of Donald Trump's
children has been a regular attendee at
these events this is a little clip from
right before Tuesday's election where
they are
striking the ground with imaginary
arrows to call upon God to win the
midterm elections for them
[Music]
Victory chat let's strike the ground and
let's give a victory Shout
on the count of three are you ready yeah
so here we go get your arrows out and
just go strike
and strike and strike strike
try come on keep going strike come on
stride come on strike the ground
[Music]
they've got the band and everything huh
that's right come on come on
this is this is I'm cringing I'm really
cringing come on
[Music]
come on victory victory victory victory
victory
okay
where is this on our Venn diagram where
is this on the Venn diagram of cult
brainwashing simple ignorance and mental
illness I think it's a very difficult
question and I think it's an interesting
question it's not about making fun of
these people now you know why it didn't
work right you know why Oz lost and
fetterman one I was striking with
imaginary arrows against us and it just
canceled it out I did it so correctly
and accurately I'm kidding but that's
why this is all so insane I don't know
the answer
I genuinely don't know the answer I
don't know whether we say this is a form
of mental illness and delusion
whether these are just folks who have
been brainwashed or whether they
ignorantly believe that striking the
ground with fake arrows affects election
results I do not know but Michael Flynn
and Eric Trump regularly participate in
these events and the interplay the
blending between
sort of elected officials although Eric
Trump isn't an elected official but
political individuals and these types of
extreme religious events there is no
fine line between them anymore they are
together the American right-wing
political establishment and the extreme
I think these are Evangelical folks
Evangelical right-wing establishment
have blended into one and that's where
we are it's really scary stuff let me
know what you make of it I used to say
find me on Twitter Twitter is
increasingly unusable because of what's
going on so make sure you're subscribed
on YouTube make sure you're following on
Twitch make sure you've liked us on
Facebook I want to hear from you where
is this on that
Spectrum or or Circle or triangle of
ignorance cult brainwashing and mental
illness let me know what you think
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is a viewer and
listener supported program we depend on
your support and it is with your support
that I believe we are going to grow the
progressive media ecosystem at such a
critical time for American politics you
can sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now yes
indeed 24 starts now let's chat with
folks from the audience we are going to
take some calls at davidpackman.com
Discord that's how we always take calls
and I want to start today with Jack from
Atlanta Jack welcome to the program
hey there David I appreciate you having
me on so I want to get straight to the
point please given the gop's
disappointing uh performance across the
country in many areas well they still
did pretty good in Florida I'm going to
ask the one question on everyone's mind
will Ron DeSantis be the GOP 2024
nominee
I have no idea personally I I think you
know we'd we first don't even know
whether he's running but there is
definitely a shifting sense that
DeSantis is increasingly the leader of
the Republican party and there's sort of
two data points for that number one
Trump's picks the Contra you know the
contested ones it's easy to pick 50
incumbents and get almost all of them
right but Trump's controversial picks
the contested picks Oz lost mastriano
lost uh Herschel Walker was still
counting ballots almost certainly going
to a runoff Blake Masters losing Kerry
lay counting okay Etc
he doesn't make a big deal out of
endorsing DeSantis on the day before the
election goes yeah yeah re-elect
DeSantis and then it's DeSantis who over
performs by seven points and wins by 19.
so there is clearly a shifting wind
we're hearing from some Republican
insiders that they say this is the
opportunity to dump Trump and the
betting markets have now shifted such
that Ron DeSantis is favored in the
betting markets to be the Republican
nominee so without injecting my personal
opinion just going into the facts it
does seem as though if both DeSantis and
Trump run
it's not a given that this nomination
goes to Trump and this could make it a
very crazy two years
oh I agree it's going to be uh one heck
of a ride so thank you very much David
my pleasure Jack from from Atlanta great
to hear from you just a reminder if you
want to get on with me today your
nickname in the waiting Lobby should be
your name and where you are calling from
um nicknames and this sort of thing uh
will will not get you on just so
everybody knows let's go next to Evan
from Las Vegas Nevada Evan welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hi David thanks for having me my
pleasure um I was wondering your opinion
about when we heard Josh Shapiro's
speech I think it was last week which
was a great speech yeah I thought he
made a great point about uh like how
Republicans have kind of become even
though they claim to be this Freedom
Party they're really the anti-freedom
party they're against abortion they're
against uh you know teaching theories
that they might agree with they're
against parents deciding with their kids
what they want to do with a doctor
Etc do you expect Democrats to kind of
use that talking point more because I
personally think it's a great talking
point I I think absolutely the case it
it I think it absolutely is the case
that it should be used listen they love
talking about freedom and yet they want
to take Freedom away from you in schools
in your bedroom at your doctor's office
and on and on and on and I think it I
think it makes absolutely perfect sense
it breaches it sort of um straddles
economic and social issues they want to
take away your freedom to organize a
union if that's what you want to do you
know all these things I think you know
your freedom to uh shop around for
prescription drugs or insurance or
whatever the case may be I think it's an
excellent talking point I'm not really
like a focus group guy so I think the
experts need to do some brainstorming
and sort of figuring out the exact right
way to do it but I think absolutely 100
percent
great yeah no I've used it just
interpersonally with friends that maybe
not aren't like crazy trumpists but I
have some friends who are like you know
kind of in the middle yeah and it seems
to click I mean they're at least they
don't have a good argument against it
you know absolutely because it's the
truth that's the reality you the the
arguments work you know Republicans have
made a pretty good Headway with
arguments that are lies but arguments
that are the truth I think work even
better
exactly okay thanks David all right
thank you my friend very much appreciate
hearing from you let's go next to Sammy
from New York City people really shot
out of a cannon uh great to hear people
getting right into their questions Sammy
welcome
hey David I hope you can hear me I can
hear you beautifully oh good
um so yeah um sounds like things did
better
um last night than we kind of expected
and I listened to your uh a live stream
that was awesome as usual my question is
and I just tuned in so I hope
um someone else didn't ask this but my
thought is
um Trump's gonna uh announce something
on November 15th but I feel like he's
gonna wait he wanted to wait in that
announce right away uh because
um he felt like
um let's just see like how all of these
elections turn out and if things are all
like in his favor then he would announce
um that he was gonna run and what do you
think or is that so I had that idea as
well but the thing is you did he's put
on he's put so much weight and made it
so obvious he plans to announce on
Tuesday that even though a bunch of the
people he picked lost I don't know that
he can go back on his word at this point
in time you know there's some
Republicans who are saying Trump's time
is over what he should do on the 15th is
say I'm not running and endorse Rhonda
Santos that's what would be best for the
Republican Party Trump's a huge
narcissist and so it's very hard for me
to imagine that he's going to do that
yeah yeah well that's true too but the
other thing is like when he when he
would say things like oh I have like I'm
gonna you know I have a better uh
insurance plan than Obamacare yeah
um and it's coming in two weeks like
everything's like it's coming it's
coming so I don't know yeah I think he
will announce I don't think this is like
the health care plan and then it'll be
interesting to see if and how the
polling shifts and if it's true that
it's Trump's for the taking or if the
betting markets are right that the
santis has a shot at this thing if he
wants it
the problem for desantises yeah Trump
can announce Tuesday and that's fine
DeSantis just got re-elected Governor
right he can't look good if he announces
a run for the presidency any time in the
next six eight or even 10 months uh yeah
so I think that that's a limitation for
DeSantis me too and even like on on the
the Florida debate when when DeSantis
was asked look are you you know tell the
Florida people like
um you're gonna
um
yeah yeah and he wouldn't answer he
looked like a deer in the headlights he
seemed to malfunction and freeze up yeah
no we'll see he that that's a
complication for DeSantis how does he
smoothly transition into that yeah and
you know David um the last time we spoke
um I said you know how amazing I think
you are and and I really you have really
turned me on to politics like I wouldn't
be listening to all of these other um
debates if it wasn't for you like live
streaming and I I really appreciate that
because well I appreciate that very much
that's why we're doing it hopefully to
get people engaged yeah and like we all
have to be
um we we have to know what's going on we
have to be informed right
um and to make the right decisions and
and I know you asked me if I was
subscribed to the YouTube channel I'm
subscribed to all three I love it Sammy
thank you so much for the call I
appreciate it of course
there is the great Sammy from New York
City with some very very positive
statements that's for sure remember that
if you want to get on your nickname in
the waiting Lobby should be your name
and your town city or town country even
if it's something other than the United
States where you're calling from let's
go next to Joseph from Oregon Joseph
welcome
hi David thanks for taking my call
um it may be too soon to tell uh but I'm
interested in what you think the results
of the midterms could mean for Trump
from a legal perspective if cons if
conservatives are suddenly ready to jump
ship for DeSantis do you think he could
finally see a courtroom I don't think I
think the answer is Trump could see a
courtroom I don't really think the
midterms are the defining Factor though
and I'll tell you why
many of the investigations have nothing
to do with the midterms in the sense
that they are state level elections and
then when it comes to the federal
election Joe Biden Remains the president
I'm sorry the federal investigation Joe
Biden Remains the president Merit
Garland Remains the attorney general and
Merit Garland made it clear whether
Trump is or isn't running and whatever
happens in the election it does not
impact how we are going to carry out the
investigation and I believe them to a
degree anyway so I actually think that
Trump may think the course of the
midterms and his potential announcement
on Tuesday will change the course of the
investigations but I don't believe that
they will
awesome thank you so much for taking my
call my pleasure great to hear from you
folks something about the calls this
week very very strong I I have to tell
you I'm liking it let's go next to Steve
from Illinois Steve welcome to the
program
Steve
oh
Steve
hello
sorry
you know I'm just I'm just learning how
uh Discord Works uh yeah so we've got a
couple of issues it sounds like you're
using speakerphone we're also hearing
all of your Discord notifications so
we've got a few different things what's
on your mind today
you know what I I really just wanted to
jump in and listen to this conversation
and see how you know I was
um
woke up this morning with uh better news
than I thought I would see
um so uh really I'm just kind of taking
in anything I um
you know can get my hands on and
literally this is my first time ever
using Discord so I really apologize no
problem Steve listen let me put you back
on hold so you can continue listening to
the conversation I really appreciate
that let's go I I don't know if this is
Austin from Louisiana or Louisiana from
Austin which which is your name and
which is your location
uh I am my name is Austin I am from
Louisiana North Louisiana got it got it
what's on your mind I just wanted to
come in and say that I was very
disappointed with my state I was really
hoping that uh Gary Chambers would get a
larger amount of the vote yeah it's very
it's very unfortunate what happened I
went and did my civic duty for the first
time I went and voted for the first time
I'm very happy about it but very not
happy with the results but yeah I didn't
really expect anything different and for
people who may or may not know the race
uh for Senate in Louisiana the incumbent
John Kennedy Republican won with about
62 percent of the vote Gary Chambers
just under 18 of the vote which is
certainly a disappointment but also not
altogether shocking I have to say
well it also has to do with the vote
being split between the two big
Democrats yes the the other Democrat had
like 12 or so right
yep yep not so good but voting was fine
did you have long lines did you have any
armed people intimidating you or
anything no I I live in a I live in a
white suburb so okay so it was pretty
easy for me no risk there yeah no it's
it's horrifying that that that that
explains it though okay so it was fine
then uh but such is the reality
unfortunately unfortunately all right
that's all thank you all right thanks
very much for the call I appreciate that
uh why don't we go
um why don't we go next
to wasif from is it is it from
Bangladesh
yes hello can you hear me I can hear you
fine wissy
oh boy hello can you hear me I can hear
you there is a very strange uh sort of
digital noise I don't know where that's
coming from
oh actually I mean you know a university
dormitory so you know you will hear some
noise I guess I gotcha is it like a
party going on in the background oh
not only a you know a lot of people are
actually in this dormitory that's why
you know the population is higher oh my
gosh okay people are studying I'm sure
it's only studying there thank you yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
okay so my question question is actually
related to a recent U.S foreign policy
you could say uh it's also related to my
country okay and that's why I wanted to
talk with you about it so
you guys know about the rohingya crisis
right yes that the you know a lot of
refugees are in my country right yes yes
originally rohingyas are from the
rakhine state of you know uh Myanmar
right so what's happening is right now
my country is actually facing a big
Colonial crisis obviously playing a part
of it and the other reason is the
establishment has some underlings who
are actually very corrupt and they have
you know done some terrible stuff with
our uh dollar Reserve basically so we
so what have what happened is that we
are you know uh very short on dollar
reserve and we are you know our
government is asking for you know if
bailouts and you know
potentially taking money from China and
not you know both of them are not really
you know being you know as good enough
as they is expected it to be so we are
having a crisis and you know the banks
are not being able to open new LCS so
the price of let's say uh uh raw
materials for you know making medicine
and electronics are you know going high
yeah so during this situation so you
know like we are asked in U.S
for help right so what their you know
giving us suggestions the what they are
providing is that they're gonna give us
you know some mental support and
something like that but they really want
to want us to do something so so what
they're saying is
I I hate to interrupt we're safe but
we're the audio is a disaster I'm not
super familiar with what you're asking
me and I'm wondering if there is a
question coming I just don't know that
I'm the right person to answer it
ah
hello I get it I'll try to end it as
soon as possible I'll try to end it as
soon as possible like one or two
sentences okay so U.S basically wants us
to
so the U.S government basically wants us
to Annex Iraq and state and you know go
go go to a war against Myanmar that's
that's what I'm saying so my question is
like right at this point when you know
the U.S is basically calling out Russia
for you know annexing all these four
different regions in Ukraine right and
they are doing the complete opposite and
you know telling us to do the same thing
that what Russia is doing right now do
you think I think you know it this is a
really a good moral ground if this kind
of news no you're you know we'll see if
you're you're exposing and how people
get American foreign policy is basically
what's useful right now I don't even
know if the things you told me are
accurate representations of what's going
on I just don't know enough about the
situation but if it were true the US is
hypocritical on foreign policy all the
time I just can't I don't even know if
what you're telling me is the case
because I've I've just I just don't know
enough about it okay well see thank you
for the call let's take a very quick
break
I I don't I just I'm not commenting on
what he said because I don't know if
it's true like the U.S is demanding that
Bangladesh do annexation I just I've not
heard that I don't know if that's true
let's take a quick break we're gonna go
back to the phones in a moment stay with
us
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people via the Discord
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to go next to
Jeremy from Suffolk in the UK Jeremy
welcome
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey um sorry I just joined you kind of
caught me off guard
um I don't necessarily think I have a
like a question per se I guess I just I
know the election's happening right now
and it's it's going much better than
what we thought but I still just have
such frustrations with um
the younger generation and um mine my
kind stems from um a military I'm
stationed here in the UK and uh I'm
gonna eat it with like 250 people and in
my section I supervise 40 plus people
and like I asked around seeing kind of
guarding interests of who's going to
register who's gonna mail them about
like none of them none of them
had zero interest in getting out to vote
and like picking their voices heard and
the most frustrating one was I have a
trans person in my flights and um when I
asked her if she was gonna vote she kind
of gave me like a shoulder shrug and I
think politics are for old people
or frustrated just kind of deal with
that kind of mentality yeah which of
course is a self-fulfilling process here
right if young people say I'm not going
to get involved because politics is for
older people they're basically seeding
that politics is for the older people
who choose to vote it's it's a
self-fulfilling endless loop
right uh the one thing I wanted to say
to her was you know there are two
political sides in our country right now
and one of those sides would attack or
not even attack you but like really
I I guess yeah attack you in the way you
choose to live your life and by you not
voting that kind of just like allows
that to continue on yep
without a doubt without a doubt uh dip
now is the politic aside from being
apathetic
is it also a right-wing group of people
you know um
so I I really I try to avoid that
conversation mostly because there are
people who are more commensurate with my
rank that I can't have that conversation
with and I will tell you most of them
are more right-leading uh I do think the
the younger crowd is left-leaning but at
the same time I try not to have that
that full discussion because it's it's
not really my place to to kind of
influence how they how they view their
politics uh I can like I can convince
them try and go out and vote but uh me
kind of expressing my ideas that's like
using my rank and my positions here to
influence them and um that's like I'm
not okay with that it's not it's
generally okay in the military
understood understood well Jeremy I
appreciate the call thank you
all right thank you all right there's
Jeremy Culligan from the UK quite a
situation he's uh facing there let's go
to uh Chris from Atlanta Chris welcome
to the program
Chris from Atlanta welcome you're on
and last chance for Chris from Atlanta
all right let's go to Aaron from Los
Angeles Aaron from Los Angeles welcome
to the show
hi David I was wondering if you um have
been keeping up with what's been
happening uh uh on with LA City policy
except a local level
um there's been quite a lot that's been
going on the past month I I really have
not
um so I guess the first thing that
happened was was our um
the city council president had to resign
following a elite audio of um a racism
Scandal oh yes I did see that yes
so there was that that occurred and now
it looks like in light of the election
it's Rick Cruz so Mike playing over
Karen bass and I'm not sure if you know
who recruso is I don't I just have not
been following that race uh yeah um so
he was actually registered as a
republican for uh years before
um switching over to the Democrat I
think around 2020
and um Karen bass is the more
Progressive candidate but in light of
everything that's happening with the
homelessness and everything else it
looks like a lot of people are going
with a more I guess center-right
candidate that's posing as a Democrat
so I yeah sorry
um I guess it's my apologies it was just
uh my question was just like very Niche
and uh based around that all right well
yeah I I am uh I apologize that I'm not
as familiar with that race as as maybe
you are but I appreciate you engaging
with it and it's really important that
we all engage with our local races you
know it's like it's it's very
interesting and relevant to follow like
does Doug mastriano become governor of
Pennsylvania fortunately he doesn't
um but for most of us the things that
affect us day to day are local issues
who's the mayor who are the city
councilors what sort of decisions are
being made in our schools Etc so good
for you Aaron for following it all
right thanks for taking my call my
pleasure there is Aaron from Los Angeles
let's go next
why don't we go to Mike from
Massachusetts Mike welcome
hey David thanks for having me on
Pleasure
um I have a couple quick questions I
know you want to get to as many people
as possible but I'll try to make them
quick uh so while there's obviously
still some uh races out there that still
need to be called important ones
um clearly this was not the red wave
that the right was you know drooling
about no you know to totally dominate
Congress and you know block everything
for Joe Biden what do you think that
I mean what do you think the Democratic
like establishment is going to take away
from this because one thing that people
have pointed out is that the only senate
seat that so far they've been able to
flip was fetterman who ran on a
relatively Progressive agenda do you
think they take anything away from this
to take it in 2024 or do they just
continue to keep the status quo because
that's just what they like to do
unfortunately or unfortunately depending
on your perspective I would say
unfortunately this was such a unique
midterm and you're right there's races
where votes are still being counted that
I don't think there is one big takeaway
and the truth is I've said for a long
time different types of Democrats make
sense in different parts of the country
would it be great to be able to run
progressives in every District every
Senate race and every governor's race
and win sure but that just simply
doesn't work that way you know up in
Massachusetts
um uh the governor's race Maura Healy
not like the Uber Progressive and when
you understand well Massachusetts has a
history
of more Centrist Democrats and
Republican Governors you have to kind of
say well if if we if we ran like a super
Progressive it might end up with another
Republican governor in Massachusetts I'm
sure you understand that and so I
sometimes I'm sorry I was going to say
in this particular case for
Massachusetts I mean the Republican
party went from a very moderate like
Baker and leaped all the way to do a
right-wing not like Neil so deal yeah I
mean deal sorry yeah
um so I mean I don't I think it was
always a foregone conclusion that Maura
Healy had this one in the bag yes no
maybe it's not the best example this
particular year but it is sort of an
example so I think the takeaway from
four Democrats really needs to be uh
different different candidates in
different races can make sense
don't compromise on what are the most
important uniting values and I would say
one thing about fetterman you know I
don't there was this confusing moment
about fracking at the end of the day
fetterman said he's for fracking so it
he sort of backed off of as Progressive
a campaign as he had been running and I
know that there was some confusion
during the debate about that but he was
like no no I'm four fracking I'm four
fracking so did he really run as
progressively as maybe you're
characterizing I don't know but listen
it's a great thing that fetterman won
that's fair I I agree with that uh one
more if you'll allow me and I'll let you
move on
this one's probably gonna get a few eye
rolls from from the listeners but
I I've just been really thinking about
this and maybe the perspective has
changed since this election didn't go as
we thought it might but
I mean do you do you feel like as a
country we're approaching a position
where
you know just based on the division that
we have they're reconcilable differences
I mean do you think we're approaching a
point where we have to have a legitimate
conversation about
doing do is it the best is it in the
everyone's best interest to keep the
country together I mean is do you think
we're approaching a point where we have
to have a legitimate conversation about
breaking the country up into two or more
pieces I don't and the reason why
honestly is exactly as you said two or
more there's a lack of contiguity in
exactly how you would do it even if we
agreed we've got to do it and it makes
sense which I don't believe anywhere
near a plurality of people are at
um I actually don't know geographically
that there's any you would end up
needing like six countries and obviously
that's not gonna happen you know
Fair it's just hard to it's hard to
imagine how we keep moving forward in a
positive direction yeah how do we live
with these people I mean it's an
alternate reality an alternate set of
moral values it's no bar is too low for
any candidate no matter what as long as
they're not a Democrat Herschel Walker
being the perfect example it's crazy I
share the the desperation I just don't
think chopping the country up into two
or more pieces is going to be a thing in
the next few years
I know and I don't know if that would be
the best move because that would remove
a serious roadblock for countries like
China and Russia absolutely you know
never mind the chaos it would reek
domestically
fair fair it's just it is hard to
imagine how we keep moving forward with
such drastic differences I'm with you
all right thank you for your time all
right thanks Mike from Massachusetts
great to hear from you let's go um let's
go back to Chris from Atlanta who says
uh he has fixed his audio Chris welcome
hey thanks Dave you can hear me this
time yes
wonderful wonderful well uh yeah I was
just sitting here you know watching
election results and everything and
um was kind of thinking about the Stacey
Abrams race and I wanted to get your
take on it as far as you know maybe
where you think
uh her campaign failed if you're that
familiar with it and and if you could
maybe compare and contrast say her
campaign to
a similar one like Beto O'Rourke
um you know kind of similar matches
there going up against incumbent
Republicans and yeah listen where they
failed and where they did well I don't
know that Abrams failed per se I think
there were a bunch of different things
going on one is that Georgia really is a
red State particularly internally even
though you know Biden won the presidency
Georgia really is a red State when it
comes to their internal politics it's
difficult to knock off an incumbent
governor
Kemp to some degree resisted Trump's
urges to overturn the election in 20. so
not only did you have I mean listen
none of the Trump people were going to
vote for Stacey Abrams and then in
addition you have Republicans who may
not have been big on Trump who probably
saw Kemp as like hey you know what he's
one of the good Republicans Trump asked
him for 11 000 votes and he didn't do it
uh so so that helped him a little bit
and I I think it was mostly that I mean
I I think Stacey Abrams is a great
candidate now you could say well Stacey
Abrams is black was the racism was race
a factor she lost by a lot you know so
of course you you can't ever eliminate
that as a factor but I think it's more
sort of like the status quo of Georgia
Internal politics
right I mean race and gender aside I
mean that's a big a big hump to over
overcome in the first place but from
from my perspective you know in Georgia
and you know watching the media and
everything like that is is from my
perspective she didn't quite fight hard
enough and was a wasn't vocal and out
there in the news cycle enough you know
I feel like they she kind of
almost fell into the Trap of the GOP
where they said all right well we're
just we're going to bring Herschel and
let Herschel dominate our voters are
going to vote for us you know down
ballot are for the most part anyway I
mean that happened but I don't know how
much it was an overt strategy
of the GOP yeah you mean
right maybe not not strategy like all
together for all their races but you
know I think they definitely
you know Stacy and her campaign
had opportunity to to be more visible
and they just weren't you know
visibility also depends on the media's
willingness to cover you you know and
you're right that the Walker Warnock got
a lot more oxygen and we did what we
could we would regularly cover the race
cover her debate cover the disaster of
Brian Kemp but part of that is also the
idea
but similar to Beto I mean you make your
own news
we have to get out there listen I think
she's great I think she's great and
sadly I do too didn't prevail
yeah same all right my friend Chris from
Atlanta great to hear from you great to
hear from everybody who I was able to
speak to today we're going to take a
quick break and I promise you we are
going to take calls again
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to the mailbag for
the week info
davidpackman.com uh I don't know if it's
because it's election week or what
happened this week but some really just
like extra wacky stuff came in and of
course you all know I love to address
substantive critiques let's start with a
message from silky about why I'm a
coward and a hypocrite okay silky says
hello Pac-Man Fever da da da I don't
know I saw your recent video where you
watched the fetterman Oz debate and you
really showed your hypocrisy when you
admonished people in your chat for
saying things you didn't like about
fetterman because you hate your audience
um that didn't happen what I said was
the people
overtly making fun of the fact that he
had a stroke
that was in poor taste and I stand by
that
person goes on to say uh mainly
questioning his mental faculties which
is a valid concern okay that's not what
they were doing what's interesting
though right silky is you're constantly
saying similar things about Trump Lake
Marjorie Taylor green and other
conservatives even Tulsi gabbard
questioning their mental state and
health
that is not true
that is not true this is a person who
has not actually listened to what I've
said when it comes to Trump
we have had long time concerns about the
glitching and the twitching and the you
know getting confused about what's
coming out of his mouth saying we need
to look into the oranges of the
investigation and he looks confused and
he can't get the word he wants we've you
know Rudy giuliani's sitting in front of
him and he starts looking around where
is Rudy where's Rudy's three feet away
that's Trump okay
Lake and Marjorie Taylor green
it's a disconnection from reality and a
sort of radicalized ignorance so it's
it's different I've never thought that
Lake and Marjorie Taylor green
we're having cognitive issues I think
they're nuts I think they're dangerous
but in any case this is as usual someone
who is reacting to things I haven't said
and Tulsi I've never talked about Tulsi
in this context
and the lastly silky says and in vain
with that
I think you mean in that vein why don't
you invite some of these people onto
your show you do have a large enough
platform if they truly are as mentally
unstable as you constantly claim you
should have no issue debunking their
arguments or making them out to be fools
but you won't because you're a coward
we've invited all of these people they
refuse to come on
I had Ben Shapiro on some years ago it
was fine it didn't go great for him but
it was it was a fine it was hugely
embarrassing he's refused to come back
on ever since
so they are invited and people say David
you criticize Jordan Peterson why not
have him on I've had them on and we've
invited him multiple times he refuses to
come on okay so come on guys try try to
try to just be a little bit more
reasonable in these emails uh Patrick
Rhoden who also writes in as Donna all
the I guess it's Donna writing in as
someone named Patrick I don't know
and uh Donna says Dave you can spin it
any way you want
I live in Upstate New York and oil and
electric prices have tripled and winter
is not even here groceries through the
roof if we don't become energy
independent again it will it will get
worse economically everyone knows that
energy is the heart of our survival so
spin it over and over again I still
listen to you once in a while yet this
is this is someone who
just doesn't know what's happening first
of all if you said to someone
what does it mean to be energy
independent what do you think they would
say I think a lot of people if you said
energy Independence they would say we
domestically produce all of the energy
we use now when Trump has been talking
about energy Independence he's not even
talking about that Trump's talking about
the import export numbers specifically
for oil
that's what Trump is talking about and
in the last couple years of trump as
well as in the first year of Biden the
U.S roughly exported as much oil as we
imported that's what they mean by energy
Independence so two things one it's not
really energy Independence it's talking
about the trade balance on oil
and two it hasn't really changed since
Joe Biden replaced Donald Trump
do you think Donna has any idea about
that I think the answer is no do you
think Donna's mind would be changed if I
presented her with this information or
him if it's Patrick I don't know
I think the answer is clearly no
Mimi wrote in about a free membership
and says hello Mr Pacman good evening
I would love to have a free membership
but can't afford it I'm on a fixed
income I want you to know keep doing
what you're doing keep up the good work
okay
I've said this a hundred times before
Mimi we love you here let me once get on
the record how to get free memberships
okay you can't email me about it you go
to davidpackman.com free membership
there's three fields to put in
first name last name email
you put your name on the list in order
we will give out the free memberships
you'll be notified by email do not email
about the free memberships go to
davidpackman.com free membership they're
available Timothy wrote in about phone
banking this is a really important email
yo David you say phone banking is
important and I agree the problem is
these Democratic committees want you to
do it on their time and on their terms
I've reached out to many different
Democratic committees saying can you
give me a list of Pennsylvania Democrats
or Bucks County Democrats and I'll call
them to get out the vote the reply is
always we don't do it that way anymore
but we do it this way they go on to
explain they meet up on zoom on a
Saturday or Sunday everyone does it
together I don't like this give me a
list of people and I'll call them if I
get done the list I'll come back for
another list I feel like these
Democratic committees are getting in
their own way yeah listen
I am guessing that when it comes to
phone stuff and giving people
information about people's phone numbers
or different things there's probably
some privacy regulations that need to be
adhered to but I agree with you it can
be way too complicated to help I've
heard from a ton of people who say I
wanted to phone bank
they told me first I've got to attain
attend two different training sessions
via Zoom at really inconvenient times
to only get on the list and then I
needed to sign up for a shift I get it
everybody has processes you got to have
a process you got to vet people all of
it
but you're dissuading people from doing
it there are people who would love to
phone bank but they can't do two
training sessions during work hours
to only get to the point where then they
can pick a shift so I I do think
something needs to happen I don't know
what it is but I've heard that from a
lot of people Dan wrote in about Jordan
Peterson and Jordan says why is it that
nobody has pointed out to Jordan
Peterson and others like him that the
justification they use for religion
gender roles Etc are the same as those
for the authoritarian governments he's
literally saying Society doesn't
function properly when people don't fit
into their prescribed role all while
lambasting socialism and communism for
their supposed lack of freedoms not sure
I'm making my point well
but it's really kind of comical if you
follow what I'm getting at I do
a lot of these folks like Jordan
Peterson say
communism and socialism are bad because
they dictate how people should behave
what type of job they should have
all of these different Norms they take
away Freedom which capitalism leaves for
people but on the other hand they are
extraordinarily authoritarian in how
they believe Society should be
prescribing whether it's gender roles or
behavior or whatever the case may be
that's absolutely true if you presented
this to them they would say
Society is just a reflection of what the
people want
whereas a communist or socialist
government is an authoritarian
imposition and I do think that that's
valid the problem is you can get around
that by saying we're not Communists and
socialists we just want to elect people
who will actually do the things we want
them to do and then it is much more
equivalent to saying well Society or
Media or whatever so good luck
explaining that to them uh but it's a
it's a very good point
Shayna wrote in about YouTube and says
hey David I've had a paid membership to
your show for several years but just
realized I'm not actually subscribed to
your YouTube channel I am now just
thought I'd mention it and encourage
other people to check love the show
thanks for your excellent work yes there
are two things going on one
fandom unsubscribes there are people who
genuinely were at some point subscribed
to YouTube and they report I'm no longer
subscribed I'm not claiming YouTube is
unsubscribing people could be a glitch
could be anything
double check and number two there's tons
of people who see our Clips on their
home uh page on YouTube so they don't
even think I need to do anything else
hit the Subscribe button it won't really
change anything you're already seeing
our Clips but it is a really big deal
for those subscriber numbers to continue
growing it signals to YouTube to keep
recommending our Clips to more people so
appreciate that very much Shayna Neil
wrote in about something a couple people
called to my attention and said so on
your Discord it was brought to my
attention that your Google profile info
comes up as conspiracy theorist which I
find hilarious considering the time
you've spent dedicated to combating many
conspiracy theories that are harmful and
unsupported one thing to note is Google
pulls this from your Wiki page which
seems to be corrected
but for me and everyone on the Discord
who checked it seemed to be pulling some
old info yeah I I saw this here's what's
going on there is a fight happening on
both my personal Wikipedia page and the
show Wikipedia page essentially with
vandals it's called vandalism on
Wikipedia where they just come through
and because anybody can edit they'll put
in anti-semitic stuff about me or
conspiracy theorist or whatever the case
may be it's mostly caught automatically
and fixed
um but every once in a while like when
it heats up the pages get locked so no
one can edit imagine having such a sad
life that you go around vandalizing
Wikipedia Pages it's it's just it's
really pathetic Mary wrote in about Mike
pillow pillows and says hey David
watched your show about using mic
pillows pillows they are awesome
I've had mine for three years works
wonders for my neck however he's a
complete idiot and I will never buy his
pillows again yeah people have written
in most to be perfectly honest most of
the people who write in say the pillows
are not good
but a couple people like Mary have
written in and said no that the guy's
Bonkers but he does have a good pillow
as I said during our interview I'm glad
to try my pillow pillows he said he was
sending them to me for me to review them
and that his assistant would reach out
nobody ever reached out I didn't get the
pillows so make of it what you will but
I'm still still waiting still glad to
try them not so concerned that I'm gonna
go buy one myself but if he sends one I
will try it get your emails in info
davidpackman.com we are now into the
post 2022 midterm phase
and it's going to get very very nuts we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and next week we are uh we're hitting
the ground running that's for sure